when I've mentioned this a couple times
here when sargon of akkad
got booted off patreon and Jordan and I
started discussing what to do and you
know our personal circumstances and
finances are very different he was in
the middle of crushing it on the
bookstore and sold millions and millions
of copies of the book and was doing
super super well from the tour and I'm
obviously doing fine and all that I'm
doing better than fine
but if but as I told you before about
70% of our monthly rev was coming off
patreon and a normal person in business
it's not just I'm not just funding
myself here we have several employees
our team is growing you know we have
called full timers we have part-timers
all of this stuff we've got capital and
overhead and all all this stuff right
and I wanted to take a stand and I
thought if I cancel patreon and try to
do this on my own like I don't know
what's gonna happen what if I lose what
do I lose that 70% what if no one wants
to come over what not even because
people don't like me what if people are
just lazy like they're just like oh
Kent's patreon I got counseled like I
guess I could go over there but like I'm
busy everyone you know there's something
on Netflix like that's it right you just
forget about it
and I my feeling was I have to do what I
think is right but I did call some
people I called so I don't want to get I
don't want to out anybody but I'm gonna
I'm gonna out one guy here I won't out
some of the other people but I called
several people some of them who have
been on this show so influential people
who are in the business who get it and I
asked several people what they thought I
should do and it's it's pretty rare that
I would call like several people asking
for advice on the same thing but I
really didn't know what to do I knew I
wanted to leave patreon I wasn't sure we
could we could fund this properly you
know finally I felt like my life is sort
of being stable I you stepped dead I
don't have dead anymore like all of
these things and I call a couple people
in a couple people who I'm not gonna
mention might surprise you in that they
actually did tell me you know just suck
it up for now this isn't the hill to die
on just let it be you know it'll blow
over you know whatever and then I called
Glenn Beck okay
and I called Glenn Beck and he said like
without hesitation like I was like Glenn
I'm thinking about canceling the patreon
account and he's like yes do it he's
like you got to take risks in life go
ahead and do it and do and do it and he
just he had such passion the way he was
saying it look here's a guy who's taking
big risks and
if he bounced around on some cable
channels he was hated for a long time
he's had Mia culpas about that I think
he's he's a really great guy I think
he's basically a libertarian who wants
to live and let live I think that you
know he's apologized for some of the
mistakes he's made in the past but he's
taken big risks right across the board
and the way he said it I when I hung up
the phone I was like I was like how
could I not take that advice you know
like how could I not take that advice
the guy who's telling me do what I
believe in take a chance take a risk
like what does everyone do in a movie
what all the heroes do in movies that
you know the does the hero get
challenges like maybe maybe tomorrow you
know can't someone else do it